Apple just released something that
people are saying could be the best
thing that they have done this year
their favorite Apple update or product
and the number one feature that they've
been waiting for for years and with that
the FBI is not so happy so in this video
I'll explain exactly what it is how you
can set it up and start using it today
and why it really matters so make sure
to pay attention now right away so many
people are giving props to Apple they're
saying we finally have good news we're
getting some great memes coming out of
this and it is absolutely free which
also means that competing products are
going to start losing money there are
actually three different layers to this
and one thing that you absolutely have
to know so starting out with the main
news that Apple announced end-to-end
encryption options for iCloud photos
notes backups and much more now nobody
was expecting this so it was a great
announcement and I know it might sound
sound boring but I'll explain exactly
why it's important now Apple already has
really great security and privacy
specially compared to other platforms
but this adds additional privacy for
your device backups and message backups
for your iCloud Drive notes photos
reminders voice memos Siri shortcuts and
wallet passes now this is full
end-to-end encryption now that means
that not only is your info encrypted
that also means that nobody has access
to it not even apple and to prove that
they say that if you lose your account
they can't fix it for you you're gonna
have to have one of the backup options
that only you have access to this is
called Advanced Data protection and it
is the highest level of protection that
you can have now you can turn it on
yourself and you can actually turn it
off at any time now you might say why
does this even matter I have nothing to
hide and I feel kind of the same way but
there have been so many leaks over the
years iCloud photos leaking where
celebrities had a bunch of photos they
didn't want leaked out there there's
breaches for credit card information
private information that goes out I've
had my accounts hacked before which
really sucked now that we're relying
more and more on our phones when you
have cameras that are being hacked uh
smart devices even being able to unlock
your house or your garage that can be
hacked something like this makes a
massive difference and it matters who
holds the keys and in this case even
Apple won't for example with Google they
store the keys themselves that also
means there's back doors for other
people to be able to access your
information and with that we've had many
companies for example Google where
employees would go and access
information and spy on emails chats and
things like that and with the majority
of encryption including what Apple had
four even though they say your data is
safe Whoever has the keys can still
access it and look at things like your
chats photos things like that but that
ends with end-to-end encryption which is
exactly what Apple just did and the
really cool thing is that this
announcement came out saying that's
going to come with iOS
16.2 and then two days later we have the
drop for that update so you can use this
right now and the day after the FBI came
out and they said that n10 encryption is
deeply concerning while at the same time
privacy groups are hailing Apple's new
Advanced Data protection it's a victory
for users so here we have quotes from a
lot of different groups for example
um the people that run signal that has
encryption saying that's a great thing
surveillance technology companies are
saying this is essential and it's
overdue and apple is pushing all this
forward so of course iPhones have had a
lot of privacy for many years and way
better than other brands that mine your
dad and sell it but for example messages
when I would text since I have backup to
the cloud and it's getting sent to the
servers that did not have great
protection and it was able to be
accessed but now you can have backups
enabled and still have encryption and
all your data cannot be accessed by
anybody now in addition to this we have
another major win where Apple abandoned
their controversial photo scanning that
was done on device now there are good
things about it but there was a huge
outcry of people not wanting all their
data being scanned all their photos for
privacy concerns and apple came out with
a statement saying that after extensive
consultation with experts they have
decided to not move forward with this
previous proposal where it would just
happen without any of your consent and
of course with that a lot of people
commenting on this saying that this is
the right move there's other ways to do
protection and this is a major step in
the right direction of course it was a
backlash of the people that made this
happen and that is also why we tell you
guys to do make a fuss when Apple does
things wrong because they do listen they
do make changes with the 16-inch MacBook
Pro they added back ports they added
back magsafe by the way if you want to
get a great deal on one right now we
have the YouTube shopping you guys can
go check that out right over there and
with the M2 MacBook Air well we talked
about the SSD situation I don't know if
that will get fixed but Apple does
listen so it's good to talk about these
things now with all this they made
another announcement which is great and
that is a fact that you can now use
physical security key support for Apple
ID to factor authentication I already
used this after I got hacked before but
you know when you get a pop-up when
you're logging in you get the code on
another device you don't always have
internet connection you could be remote
and you can get locked out well now
there's going to be multiple ways to
have your own personal key or physical
key to be able to log into your devices
now there is one downside to this which
I'll mention a set but I want to say the
Apple has multiple pages about what
they're doing exactly how it works if
you want to get into the nitty-gritty
but I do want to show you guys this one
section where with iCloud that gives you
info and it shows you exactly what can
get end to end encrypted on here for
example your help data home data payment
information
Maps you have your Wi-Fi passwords W1
and H1 Bluetooth Keys over here which is
very important because now I'm using
that for unlocking my home and even
memoji are end-to-end encrypted meaning
Apple doesn't have access to all of the
things that are here so the downside is
that this new encryption can't be
enabled from new devices right way
meaning if you just bought a new iPhone
you'll have to wait to be able to enable
it it's not on by default but for older
devices that is you know it's your phone
so it's not somebody that just buys a
new phone gets into your account and
enables this and can lock them out
you're able to set this up and with that
you do have to have IOS 16.2 to be able
to enable it and thankfully it's
available right now so you can go and
download it and you also have to have
your other devices around your account
updated to the latest version now the
main downside is that if you have
devices that cannot be updated to new
versions of iOS so if they're really old
devices then you're kind of locked out
because as soon as you enable it on your
phone it actually works across all of
your devices and since it's on your
device it has to run and be capable of
doing that so some people might have to
remove all devices if they're not using
it or upgrade so now now how do you
enable this to keep all hackers leakers
and everybody else out when your data is
secure so you're going to go into your
settings on your phone you want to click
on your Apple ID and then you're going
to press on iCloud scroll down to the
bottom and then you'll see Advanced Data
protection it's going to show you all of
the things that are going to be end to
end encrypted here which is really cool
first you want to do the account
recovery setup because you need to make
a recovery and a key so you want to
select that on there the whole thing is
really easy and quick to do even though
it's hidden in the menus I'm going to go
ahead and set up my recovery key here
I'm not going to show you guys what this
key is because it's my recovery key and
Bam it is done you'll get an email from
Apple saying that there's a new recovery
key you want to make sure you keep this
safe make sure you'll know what it is
and then lastly we're going to turn on
Advanced Data protection now as you guys
see it's telling me that I have to wait
till January 14th because I just bought
a bunch of new Apple devices that is
totally fine by me me I'm gonna hit OK
and once that date comes I'm going to be
able to enable this so set a reminder
for yourself or if you don't have any
Apple devices it will work right away so
I think this is a huge win for all sorts
of people it's a huge one for privacy
you guys let me know your thoughts
um down in the comment section below
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there this Max and I'll see
you in the next one
[Music]